شهدت مدينه مالمو السويديه مظاهره حاشده
دعم للفلسطينيين وردد المتظاهرون بالاوضاع
غير الانسانيه التي يعيشها الفلسطينيون من
سكان القطاع كما طالبوا بوقف القصف
الاسرائيلي على غزه وطالبوا بالحريه
لفلسطين كما خرجت في العاصمه الالمانيه
برلين مسيره حاشره تندد بالهجمات
الاسرائيليه المتواصله على قطاع غزه
الفلسطيني منذ السابع من اكتوبر وعرب
المشاركون في المسيره عن تضامنهم مع الشعب
الفلسطيني ورددوا هتافات تطالب بالحريه
لفلسطين وننوه الى هذه
الصور التي تاتينا مباشره من بيروت ورام
الله وواشنطن
لهذه الوقفات الاحتجاجيه المسانده للشعب
الفلسطيني مع دخول الحرب العام الجديد في
قطاع غزه ننوع ايضا الى الاخبار العاجله
التي ظهرت على شاشتنا فيما يتعلق بالملاحه
البحريه في باب المندب وزير الدفاع
البريطاني يقول نحن على استعداد لاتخاذ
اجراءات مباشره لردع التهديد الذي تتعرض
له الملاحه في البحر الاحمر وان هذا هو
الانذار الاخير لمن يعطلون التجاره في
البحر
الاحمر الان الى ابرز ما
ورد نبقى بعض الوقت مع هذه المظاهرات
بمناسبه العام الجديد تضامنا مع الشعب
الفلسطيني في قطاع
[تصفيق]
غزه شو
الاخبار هاي نيوير